ha ha  Nazi scum you stayed with us for 14  years  the Nazis rule the world now  I'll find the resistance I'll find them  and I'll help them fight BJ Blazkowicz I  thought it was a goner knew you are back  from the dead ready I said thanks rate  Wyatt  we are finally strong enough to strike  at sir operations so days of scurrying  like rats are over general deaths head  is nearer to us now than he's been in  years  the Eliminator general we cover head off  the crow war machine there is a one more  thing it's quite critical  I like you such a resilient specimen  you  let me tell you how this is gonna work  I'm gonna ask you one question  you are gonna answer that question in a  way I find satisfactory and if you do  not I will saw your head off with this  year appliance you hear me sir let me do  that if I - done  she's the taifa ha  Luke shine pop plop nimda Schmidt - Mia  stretchy tonight house